please stand for the chairman of Sunny
District Council
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I'll welcome you to this meeting
of the council
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the office via the stairs either
through the secondary security doors to
my right or the opposite lift in the
foyer
please do not use a lift please assemble
in hallway Square on the green officers
will assist you and advise you when it
is doomed to be safe to return
I would advise
that if filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
periodically if there is any children
present
because every anyone intend to film the
meeting
right
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
where exempts or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public
from the meeting
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phone
I'll turn to silent and that they are
not used to make
or receive
phone calls whilst this meeting is in
progress
agenda item one
I have
been any counselors got any apologies
no we're all here right right item two
minutes of the previous meeting I move
that the minutes of the meeting of the
council held on the 18th of May 2023 be
approved and signed as correct record
with the vice chair please second
seconded do members agree
thank you
agenda item three announcements
please note that
when I'm there
right announcements I I am sad to inform
counselors that the former counselor
John Kirby has passed away
I would ask members to pause for a
minute silence in respect of councilor
John Kirby
[Music]
thank you
yeah
is there anybody that wishes to speak
Rogers
counselor Rogers
thank you chairman
I first met John when I owned a business
in Grange Road Ramsgate and he had the
posters post office opposite
John abena County and District councilor
a magistrate mayor of Ramsgate and
chairman of this Council it was John and
his wife who encouraged me into politics
and gave me an enormous amount of
support John was a kind honest man with
a great sense of humor and we became
good friends
John and Jill retired to driftfield in
Yorkshire 2015 and I took his district
seat he kept in touch and I visited a
couple of times he will be sadly missed
by all who knew him
well right thank you
a agenda item four
Declarations of Interest are there any
decorations of Interest
ing agenda item five petitions
no new petitions ever received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
12.
agenda item six questions from the press
and public
there have been five questions received
from the press and public in in
governance with the council procedure
rule 13.
please note only the questioner and the
respondents are permitted to speak on
the question
good the questioner please only state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
they question is to be put and read out
the exact wording of the question that
they submit to the council
item agenda 6A question number one from
a member of the public regarding noise
disturbance from cramptons
I I am pleased to welcome Mr Knowles to
the meeting could you please make your
way to the microphone
so we will contact Mr Knowles in writing
foreign
number two from the member of the public
regarding protection of farmland
I am pleased to welcome Ms Brown to this
meeting could you please make your way
to the microphone
good evening I'm Jackie Brown and I'm
representing westgating Action Group
against Housing Development on farmland
and my question is to the leader uh
recover it please
if the new administration at TDC prepare
to continue the work that the former
leader of the council Ash Ashby started
and lobbied the Secretary of State the
department of leveling up housing and
communities to consider than it as a
special case and Grant protection to the
district's Farmland due to the Rarity
across the country of the grade of
farmland and favorable growing
conditions that exist in thanet
thank you
thank you chair and thank you Mr Brown
for your question
um yes we're very proud of the Farmland
that we've got in Planet and we want to
preserve it as far as we possibly can
the council responded to the
government's consultation on draft
changes to the National planning
Guidance the nppf
details of which are on the council's
website this sets out among other
matters that the case the case that the
government should give specific
protection to best and most versatile
Farmland grades one two and three a
at the same time the labor group via
councilor Whitehead submitted its own
response to the mppf consultation and
you'll be pleased to hear this took a
similar view
so the council's position on this issue
Remains unaltered by the change of
administration
both major parties in thanet support the
view that stronger protection is needed
then the government has so far proposed
thank you
my thank you
item agenda item 6C question number
three from the member of the public
regarding public toilets
I am pleased to welcome Miss ferry to
the meeting and could you please make
your way to the microphone
hi I'm Karen Fury I'm
I want to speak to councilor Alban
um I'd like to ask why the public
toilets at local beaches are closed so
early for instance dumped in gap the
toilets close at 3 30. the cafe has a
license to remain open until 8 PM there
are over 30 Beach Huts there there are
no other facilities nearby children have
just left school and with a light
evening surely the toilets should be
open for longer on Stone Bay it's 1610
Jos Bay 1645 on Facebook group then it
hurts there are so many comments
regarding the state of the toilets or
lack of them this leaves many people
without essential hygiene facilities
visit England carried out a survey in
2019 and 54 of visitors cited public
toilets affected where they would visit
thank you
all right thank you Mr I called upon
councilor Alban to respond thank you
chair yeah and thank you mrery for your
for your question
um
there are 28 public toilets in Senate
uh they're not all open according to the
summer opening times which can be found
on the council's website
there's very little change to what was
there last season the the the times are
still the same
um the majority of our toilets are
cleaned by three mobile units each
consisting of a member of cleansing team
working from a small van
at Margate Viking Bay and Ramsgate Sands
static cleaners are deployed
due to the high footfall in those
locations the level of available
resources and the need for cleaning at
each site are both factors in
determining the opening and closing
times of each location
the rotor for unlocking and lock-in is
set for to ensure the facilities in the
area with the highest number of visitors
are open for the longest period
at locking up time staff working teams
to protect them from the anti-social
Behavior which can occur in certain
locations
and I can I can actually state that some
of our staff have been assaulted while
attempting to close the toilets
keeping toilets open beyond the early
evening presents a higher risk of
vandalism which can lead to Temporary
closure and costly repairs
for this reason the latest closing times
are between 8 pm and 8 30 at the main
Bays
toilets may also be closed up to 15
minutes prior to the publicized closing
time to enable thorough cleaning to be
completed at each location
I would also I would also State this
theory that I am happy together with the
director to look to see whether we can
extend some of the times to the smaller
Bays thank you
thank you Council album
agenda item 6D
question four
from a member of the public regarding
Brownfield sites I'm pleased to welcome
Miss McCall to the meeting could you
please make your way to the microphone
good evening thank you my question is
directed to Rick Everett and my question
is we have Brownfield sites at Tivoli
Road and at station yard
All Saints Avenue Margate
two Builders businesses use these
locations which are within residential
areas
our previous leader advised that a
Russian owner was linked to the station
yard site who was uncontactable I
believe that this council could take
action and where necessary compulsory
purchase these Brownfield sites for
housing
empty homes and businesses in and around
Margate and cliftonville 2 could be
developed
turning these properties and sites into
habitable homes for local people should
be a priority
what lengths will this Council go to in
order to prioritize Brownfield sites as
exampled here for housing before losing
our Prime Farmland to developers who
prioritize over providing the homes who
prioritize profits over providing the
homes for our residents our environment
wildlife services and air quality is in
Jeopardy unless this Council does all it
can to stop the loss of our precious
Farmland thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr Nicole can I pull up on the
leader to respond
all right thank you chair and uh thank
you Mr cool
um the identification of suitable
Brownfield sites for development is a
key part of the local plan process and a
similar process is being undertaken for
the local Plan update
however the local planning Authority
also has a responsibility to ensure that
there is sufficient and suitable land
available to support economic
regeneration and local businesses this
includes the retention where appropriate
of existing employment sites that
contribute to that objective
the two sites mentioned have been
identified as fulfilling that purpose
and are protected for employment use in
the adopted local plan
in relation to empty homes an allowance
is already made in the local plane
agreed by the planning inspectors for
the contribution to the housing land
supply of empty homes brought back into
use
I believe that councilor Whitehead is
going to say more about empty homes in
response to a later question
but the point to make here is that an
assumption about this is already
factored into the housing number
calculation and I can tell you that it's
currently 324 over the current plan
period or 27 per year but I can also
tell you that we're intending to do a
lot better than that
thank you
agenda item 6E question number five from
member of the public regarding
maintenance of formal public gardens
I am pleased to welcome Ms Bailey to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the microphone
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening thank you my questions to
councilor Olden and I'm speaking on
behalf of the broadstairs tourism and
Leisure Association
uh the flower beds along Victoria
Gardens and in Victoria um sorry
Victoria Parade and Victoria Gardens
have always looked beautiful and have
attracted very positive comments however
this year they are overgrown with weeds
and brambles and look extremely unkempt
the bull stress tourism tourism and
Leisure Association have received
several inquiries as to what has
happened this year and where the
gardeners are could you please tell us
what has changed and what the plans are
going forward in regard to reinstating
and maintaining these formal sorry
public gardens in this popular tourist
destination thank you
thank you Miss Bailey
I called upon Council album to respond
thank you chair
firstly uh I'd like to say that uh when
dad looked for myself yesterday just to
just to see what was going on
and our staff were there working and I'm
sure you've seen over the last week that
our staff have been there working
um
but a full answer to your question
unfortunately the team are experiencing
staff shortages
this year which are coupled with
Machinery breakdowns has impacted
their ability to deliver the usual
standard of service in this location and
I totally agree with you normally it's
lovely
um
the supervisors have been working in
Victoria Gardens as I just said
over the last week or so to try and
resolve the weed issue and so I hope
that it is at least looking better
we are recruiting for the vacant post as
well as management and seasonal Rose
roles so going forward
hopefully the situation will improve
thank you
agenda item seven questions from members
of council
13 questions have been received from
members of the council
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of questions from Members
shall not exceed 30 minutes however
given that this is the first meeting
that allows for questions since March in
the next meeting after this isn't until
October I intend to allow all questions
we have received
so item
7A question number one from the member
regarding limited libel partnership I
called upon Council of wing
thank you chair I think my question is
to councilor Yates is finance or is it
to the leader am I am I right okay the
following limited liability partnership
East Kent opportunities LLP was
incorporated on the 4th of March 2008
and remains active and according to
companies house is a joint partnership
between KCC and TDC
the last set of accounts were registered
on the 2nd of November 2022 covering the
period of the Year ending the 31st of
March 2022.
for what purpose was this LLP set up how
does it generate income slash profits
and what has does this money Finance
a call upon councilor Yates to respond
thank you chair and thank you councilor
wing
East Kent opportunities was incorporated
in 2008 as a joint venture between
thanetusa Council and Kent County
council with the express aim of bringing
forward two sites in thanet in a
complementary way to support Economic
Development and regeneration in the area
due to the fact this is an economic
development regeneration project no
allowance has been made in the budget
for any income or profit
instead these have been treated as
windfalls as and when they're
materialized and in some instances in
instances used to repay investment costs
associated with unlocking the site for
example the cost of the spine road
behind Sainsbury's the west across thank
you
thank you I called upon Council of wing
do you have a supplementary question yes
I do chair thank you
uh the most recent accounts as we sent
indicate over just over 9 million in
equity and nearly a nearly 800 just over
800 000 in cash can you tell me if the
LLP is linked directly or indirectly to
any land along the Hayne Road and
whether the LLP has benefited
financially from any of the various
subsequent housing developments thank
you
thank you for that question counseling
um let me be as transparent as I can be
I can't answer that specific question
about the linkage to Hayne Road
[Music]
yeah
okay let's do that thank you counseling
agenda item 7B question number two from
a member of regarding public toilets I
call upon counselor toning
a thank you chat uh my question is for
councilor Albin
in 2019 when the conservatives were in
control
I raised the issue about tourists with
ex councilor uh
Ash Ashby
it is the question if you wait
it's about toilets now the question is
okay
sorry
well okay let me go to the question as
you know
thank you
we've got several tourists in in Italian
that are totally completely out of use
and what I would like to know when will
we get those toilets back into you so
the community and the visitors too and
it can use them when will that happen
can you tell us your plan please
right thank you
we really want to stick to the question
that's on written down
so I'll call upon councilor Alban to
respond
yeah thank you chair thank you councilor
turning what I'm going to do is I'll
read your questionnet for you
um your question we are unable to use
the public toilets in thanet
will you inform the meeting what steps
have been taken to repair and have the
toilets available for local residents
and visitors to use
there are currently 28 public toilets
open daily in Senate last week the
public toilets on Canada Street in
Ramsgate reopened the toilets were
closed in March 2022 due to continued
anti-social and criminal Behavior
we have refurbished the toilet block and
installed new litter bins and a planter
CCTV is also being installed to
discourage further anti-social Behavior
at the Block
although the toilets of Margate Clock
Tower have been closed since 2019 we
have once again put temporary toilets in
place this season
looking ahead
there is an objective to improve toilet
provision in key locations across the
district and officers are currently
scoping plans which will be shared later
this year thanks chair
thank you because the challenge you have
a supplementary question
thank you for that I'll concern
as I mentioned as my question asks a
question about when will these stories
be available for use however what you're
not telling us what the real plan is
this looks as though there's going to be
yet another review to to tell us nothing
about because we've had three reviews
previously and no one found out anything
about those reviews and we need to know
what happens so could you tell us please
yes I can tell you councilor towning is
that your
your party was in control of thanet
District Council for the last two years
and I you know for the last two years
and uh you didn't ask them what they
were doing you didn't ask your cabinet
member what that what they were doing
I've just explained that we are looking
at this we are taking this this forward
and I can tell you Council Taney that I
will get it done unlike your party thank
you
question number three from a member
regarding the right to buy housing sales
are called upon councilor bayford
chair my question is for councilor
Whitehead
to note that following pressure for many
authorities including TDC the government
has changed the rules concerning
receipts from right to buy housing sales
allowed in councils to keep 100 of the
monies raised subject to certain
conditions
with the cabinet member of housing
outline how TDC intends to take
advantage of this New Freedom over the
two years for which it is available
are called upon Council of Whitehead to
respond
thank you chair and thank you very much
councilor bayford
as you've stated for the financial years
2022-23 and 23-24 local authorities will
be able to retain the treasury share of
right to buy receipts
but these can only be utilized in the
same way as retained one for one
receipts
in 2223 the treasury share was 196 112
pounds and 11 Pence and for 23 24 we
have predicted this amount to be 65
371 pounds and 86 Pence which equates
roughly to four right by sales
it's equates to an estimate of just
under 261 500 pounds over two years
this is a welcome amount and will be
utilized as part of the 40 subsidy
required as part of the 8.1 million
already in the approved housing revenue
account Capital program to provide
additional genuinely affordable homes
for residents
our Ambitions to provide new affordable
homes are the subject of a report later
on this in this agenda and right to buy
receipts are an important part of the
funding for this program
thank you councilor bayford do you have
a supplementary question I do share
thank you and thank you for your
response councilor Whitehead you're
welcome um I'd like to buy receipts was
the topic often raised at the housing
cabinet Advisory Group which I ched
until May are there any plans to
re-establish a housing cabinet Advisory
Group which I believe was a very useful
and effective way of creating
cross-party involvement in this very
important aspect of the council's
business and if so when is this likely
to be
to respond very sorry chair thank you
chair and thank you councilor bayford
and yes as members well most members
here will remember I instituted the
housing CAG when we were in
administration previously so it's very
very important to me and it will be one
of the four cabinet advisory groups that
we are bringing forward as an
Administration very shortly
thank you
right okay agenda item 7D question
number four from the member regarding
privately funded CAF in North Dam Park I
called upon councilor manners
thank you chair my questions directed at
councilor Ruth Duckworth one of my
constituents has secured over 500
signatures in a petition calling upon
TDC to facilitate offering a concession
and thereafter inviting expressions of
interest for a privately funded Cafe
operation in Northtown park near the
children's play area
an area that is often blighted by
anti-social Behavior can this be looked
at as a priority
indeed can we now look forward to thanet
District Council encouraging Enterprise
and Community cohesion as part of its
forthcoming property strategy thank you
a call upon councilor Duckworth to
respond thank you chair and thank you
councilor manners for your question
we're currently conducting a thorough
review of North Dam Park and all its
facilities the Estates team is carefully
evaluating every aspect including the
buildings sports and recreation
facilities public conveniences
refreshments and other relevant factors
the main goal is to assess different
options and make well-informed decisions
as part of the review we are considering
the possibility of offering refreshments
and light snacks in the Parks Pavilion
subject to necessary consents it's
important for us to prioritize the
protection of our green spaces and make
the most of the existing buildings
before considering the construction of
new cafes
our aim is to ensure a comprehensive
evaluation that takes into account
feasibility of various options by
utilizing the existing infrastructure
and exploring potential enhancements we
can maintain the Park's natural beauty
while providing additional immunities
for the residents to enjoy
thank you
yes do you have a supplementary question
nope that's fine thank you
question number five from member of
regarding the Senate Theater Royal
repair and refurbishment
thank you
I'll call upon Council of Banbridge I'm
sorry about that
thank you chair
my question is for um councilor Yates
um the theater wall in Margate is a
unique piece of Margate history much
loved and much missed since its closure
recently the council has awarded 2
million from government funds towards
the theater's repair and refurbishment
out of this the sum of 370 000 was
determined for urgently needed repairs
required to keep the fine old building
wind and watertight and to protect and
prevent its condition from deteriorating
further can councilor Yates assure me
that steps will definitely be taken to
ensure that these urgent repairs will be
carried out before the onset of next
winter and can I please be advised at
the timetable for these works
thank you I called upon Council
Duckworth to respond
[Laughter]
as with all renovation projects you
often don't realize the full extent of
what needs doing until proper surveys
have been done
with the theater Royal we have
discovered the sun burner in the ceiling
which is has Heritage significance it is
an early Victorian Gaslight and
ventilation system which needs careful
investigation
in order to properly ventilate the
theater it is very likely modern plants
and extraction will need to be located
on the roof and will need to be included
in the final designs an overall master
plan is required with conservation
principles applied to safeguard the
heritage of the theater
the building will be watertight before
Autumn early winter safeguarding it
until the major Works begin
the council will be applying for
National Lottery Heritage funding in the
coming six months for the projects
thank you
thank you councilor Bainbridge do you
have a supplementary question
um yes I do um thank you chair
um
I've heard that the earmark funding from
the market Town deal for grasses to be
reallocated can this be used to further
secure the future of the theater Royal
or the Winter Gardens
call upon cancer that was to respond
please
thank you chair
um well that is not the case it hasn't
there has to be no decision about
reallocating the grass money we're still
hoping to be able to resolve the
situation with grass amicably and we're
still hoping to be able to fund that
project
thank you thank you councilor Duckworth
agenda item 7f question number six from
a member of regarding birchington
neighborhood plan I call upon Council
the cup
thank you chair I believe this is uh for
the leader we have seen an updated plan
submitted to the council for 1 600 homes
in birchington it is more important than
ever that our Villages towns like
birchington have robust and thorough
neighborhood plans in place to ensure
that there is still some level of
protection to our unique Villages and
towns
birchington's neighborhood plan has been
delayed due to circumstances with the
appointed examiner can the cabinet
member or the leader please tell me what
the council will do so that this does
not happen again to ensure we are
supporting our towns and Villages thank
you
the call upon Council Everett is from
thank you chair and thank you councilor
cut for your question
I understand that the draft neighborhood
report was expected at the end of
January this year although the process
of considering it have been ongoing
since late 2021
I'm also told that the delay to the
examination was the result of some very
unusual circumstances
however the examination fact check
report has now been received
and what we're hoping is that the final
report will be reported to cabinet at
the August meeting so the process is
accelerating
the other neighborhood plans currently
being prepared are running to the
anticipated program
councilor Cutler you asked what the
council will do to ensure this doesn't
happen again
well I think to give you a proper
response to that I'd need to speak to
somebody who had an interest in the
matter as a birchington counselor and
was in the cabinet for the entire period
from late 2021 to May 2023 to find out
why what they did to chase the matter up
during that 18-month period and while
that doesn't seem to have had any effect
I don't know if councilor cup knows
anyone who fits that description
do you have a sample of Entry question
I didn't share but I do now
um I I just like to say that I just
think it's just shows the level of
obviously clearly the politics that's
going on here but I didn't ask about
what had happened it's about what's
going to happen in the future
thank you I did answer it I did ask a
question
do you want to respond Council ever
I don't think that I don't think there's
much points to be honest with you I mean
the whole of the delay
um relates to the period the councilor
cut was in the cabinet
um he wasn't the cabinet member for
planning but I know he has a very good
relationship with the leader or the
ex-leader who was and I think it's a bit
much to come and ask me what I'm going
to do about a problem that he couldn't
solve thanks right
thank you Council Everett
agenda item 7g question number seven
from a member regarding Villages and
local plan review
are called upon Council pew
look at that thank you chair sorry I was
wondering when it was gonna get to me uh
my questions for the leader of the
council
um as the council conducts the local
plan review to extend the local plan to
cover the period of
2031-2040. what protections will be put
in place for villages in thanet to
ensure that they are protected not just
from over development but also from
merging with one another
thank you I called upon Council Everett
to respond
um thank you councilor Pugh I mean I
think this is another subject on which
we agree
um the price precise level of housing
that will need to be accommodated in the
districts under the local plan review
has not been determined not as the
location or scale of any new development
sites
decisions about local plan allocations
and other policies will be made by
members including full council at
different stages of the plan making
process
the separation of settlements has been a
feature of local plans in thanet for
many years primarily through the
Greenwich policies separating urban
areas in The Villages this is primarily
achieved by The Village confines policy
which is local plan policy SP 24.
thank you because if you do you have a
supplementary question please I do share
and thank you I thank the leader for his
response
um particularly what I'm concerned about
is that the change from the previous
local plan to the current local plan and
potentially this revised local plan
means that the designations of outside
the village confines doesn't hold the
same level of protections that the prior
designated Village gaps do now I
understand that the villages are going
to organically grow and and future
Generations need housing I completely
get that and I'm not advocating for no
Development Across The Villages at all
but what I would ask the leader is will
he consider on a cross-party effort that
for this review of the local plan and
for it to cover the entirety of the
district and in that we look at
reinstating these Village gaps to ensure
that there is proper protections because
these Village confines there's plan
applications that are going in now that
are outside the village confines and I
don't think it means as much as the The
Village gaps did before
thank you I called upon the leader of
the council Everett to respond please
um uh yes Council appeal I think
everything's up for grabs I mean we've
already been asked about the housing
cabinet Advisory Group I'm very keen and
I've been involved in the last couple of
days
in reestablishing the local plan cabinet
Advisory Group and I hope we'll get the
decision though it's out about that as
soon as possible and I think that
feedback will be a valuable part of the
process you'll be aware that the local
plan review is um again a statutory and
lengthy process and currently it's being
held up by a couple of things one of
them is obviously the situation with
manston airport which is one of the
things that we have to consider in the
local plan review but I think more
importantly now
um it's the government's changes to
planning policy and I don't think we're
going to see those changes depending
policy until next year and that's going
to slow the whole process down further
but I would absolutely welcome your
import and the import from all across
the chamber on what we should put in the
local plan review I look forward to
considering it and I think it's
important everybody understands it's not
a decision for me it's a decision for
the council thank you
oh thank you agenda item 7h question
number eight from a member regarding the
Regeneration Alliance and Ramsgate
Society proposal I call upon counselor
Davis
good evening thank you chair uh my
questions for the leader as portfolio
holder at the Portland Harbor and I will
read it so I don't go off track you'll
be pleased to hear there has been a
great deal of interest in and support
for the Ramsgate regeneration Alliance
proposal to establish a regular tall
ships event at the historic Royal Harbor
of Ramsgate this interest has come from
the public from Community groups
including the Ramsgate society and
others local businesses and the sale
training association who successfully
runs such events internationally for
many years
the project will provide huge financial
gain both to the local economy across
the island and to in fact to this
Authority can gain not to the region of
12 to 15 million pounds budget per event
that's not the authority that's the
total will the leader as portfolio
holders support this exciting initiative
with the potential to create jobs
training opportunities for Youth and a
huge boost to this Island's tourism and
Leisure economy
thank you I called upon councilor
Everett to respond
yeah unfortunately chair I've got a
whole sequence of the questions here so
you're going to get bored by the sound
of my voice where everybody else is at
any rate
um yeah it's an exciting idea councilor
Davis thank you for your question
um tall ship events have taken place at
Ramsgate before as you know most
recently in the 1990s the visit of el
Galleon earlier this year also proved to
be a popular local attraction
any new event proposal should be
submitted to the council using the
dedicated event app which can be found
on the council's website the application
can then be reviewed by relevant
officers including the Harbor Master at
Ramsgate such that feedback from an
initial assessment of The Proposal can
be given
councilor Davis has suggested that such
an event will generate employment
training opportunities and 12 to 15
million benefit for the local economy
that's a very large number so I'm
assuming that you must have the evidence
to support that claim
the details of anticipated benefits
accompanied by a robust business case
along with an assessment of enabling
costs should be included with an
application for all such major events
until the council has been provided with
that information it's not possible to
say whether we will be able to give the
green light such an event however
subject to a favorable outcome to an
initial assessment of The Proposal I
would support further officer time being
committed to offering feedback and
guidance to an organizer such that they
can further develop their plans
thank you councilor Davis you have a
supplementary question I do chair uh
thank you for the answer Council Everett
and uh it sounds pretty encouraging on
the whole because I can I'm pleased to
confirm for example you questioned the
evidence as to the revenue
um the good news is that's based on
similar events uh comparable ports that
have been running over many years as I
say with the sale training association
because the good news is the model
exists and all we have to do is Bolt it
into the asset that we have at the
harbor
um so I'd like to thank you for what
sounds like a positive uh response and
for the offer of Officer time
um what I'd like to do is uh would he
agree to meet with the directors of the
sale training association and the
relevant offices in order to progress
this further
a cortisone councilor Everett to respond
yeah I think we'd like a business case
and an outline proposal and then we can
consider having a meeting but I'm
certainly open to that suggestion thank
you thank you very much thank you chair
thank you Council Everett agenda items
seven
I I'm not 71.
questions number nine from a member of
regarding Southern water are call upon
councilor Scott
thank you chair
um I believe this is a question to the
leader uh so how does this
Administration propose the challenge
whether Southern water has the ability
to provide uninterrupted Safe Water for
all households in thanet and that the
company has extra capacity to dispose of
and treat water from the potential
twenty one thousand new homes that could
be added to the water supply and
treatment Network in Fanny the proposed
additional numbers are added to the
local plan following the review it's not
as such a satisfactory solution to have
a site to have on-site sewage Disposal
Systems or cesspits installed on new
developments with the ways being taken
away in lorries thank you
thank you I've called upon councilor
Everett to respond
thank you chair and thank you for your
question counselor Scott alongside the
local plan the council prepares an
infrastructure infrastructure delivery
plan to ensure that the necessary
infrastructure support development can
be provided this involves engagement
with a range of statutory bodies and
service providers including the
environment agency in southern water
this will also be a key part of the
local Plan update process
just to be clear though none of the
current plans for the Strategic housing
allocations in the 2020 local plan
include on-site sewage Disposal Systems
so I think that's possibly a bit of a
red herring
it should be noted that in 2024 the
right to connect to the sewage Network
as part of new development is to be
removed from surface for surface water
runoff which is the primary component
that results in flooding and sewage
relief
I understand that when these events are
triggered as much as 97 of the water in
the system is surface water runoff
as to what we're going to do about it
since being elected in May I've been
speaking to other leaders across Kane
about this and there's a collective view
that we need to act together to
challenge the water companies that
operate in the county rather than just
as individual authorities
further discussions are due to take
place about that in the near future
because we all recognize that the
current situation is unacceptable
unfortunately we can only seek to
influence as we do not have any pounds
to act in this area but by working
together we believe there is more chance
of our voice being heard
thank you counselor Scott do have a
supplementary
uh yes I'll do your chair and uh yeah
thank you for your answer I think you
covered some of it but I will just ask
it out as if I pull it in so I do want
to reiterate the concerns of the
viability of the current current
of fan its current water system and its
future position provision given that we
again have had enough a discharge that
affected the district last week we must
be mindful that other water companies
such as Thames water are collapsing due
to mishandling of repairs sword flooding
and customer satisfaction what actions
will the council take to ensure Southern
water avoid this or at least pursue the
company for reparations for the
financial Community as part as per our
previous administration did
thank you a call upon councilor Everett
to respond well I think we all I think
we all agree that the situation is
unacceptable and um you know I don't
think anybody anybody wants to defend it
what I would say is that as welcome as
the reparations from Southern water may
have been they haven't solved the
problem as is perfectly clear I think we
need a more comprehensive approach and I
think we need to involve all the
districts and um in the uninsure
authority in the county to basically get
our voice heard so that's where I'll be
directing my efforts in the short term I
don't think getting small pots for money
is the answer to the problem in fact I
think it gives it lets Southern water
off the hook it lets them think that
they've bought us off and I don't think
we should be bought off I think we
should keep going after them
thank you agenda item 7j question number
10 from a member regarding collaborative
working with town and Parish councils I
call upon councilor fellow
thank you Mr chairman uh shortbread
Concepts so everyone can understand my
question during the last term a
cross-party scrutiny panel working group
shared excellently by your very own
Council Cory understand put together a
review on how town and Parish councils
can work collaboratively with TDC the
review was complete and a number of
excellent recommendations have been put
forward now due to the election and the
change of administration the progress of
the review through cabinet has stalled
so my question is to councilor Everett
will he give his assurance that the
excellent scrutiny review be progressed
through cabinet as soon as possible so
the recommendations put forward by the
working group can be implemented these
recommendations will benefit all our
residents and are wanted by town and
Parish councils and will also help
relieve some pressure on services
offered by TDC and hopefully create a
better working relationship between TDC
and town and Parish councils
thank you God call upon Council Everett
desperun
yes
do you have a yes yes Council fellows
supplementary
uh thank you leader for the excellent
answer uh I do have a brief uh follow-up
and it's really just to ask him if he
push uh for TDC to create a better
culture and dealing with town of Parish
Council so they can be treated as the
powerhouses of local representations
that they are and not treated as the
poor relations that this so often
happens
I'll call a phone Council Everett to
respond
yes well I'm tempted to say that um you
know I've been particularly impressed by
the work that's been done in ramscape by
Ramsgate Town Council but I'm sure
you'll think that that's a political
Point
um and and I'm looking forward I'm
looking forward after the election
results to working more closely with
broadstairs and some Peter's Town
Council and with Westgate Town Council
um you know I think we can if we can
play politics with it but I actually
think that the town of Paris council is
a very important part of our of our
Democratic setup in thanet and I do
think that they can do things in their
areas that TDC finds it difficult to do
and I look forward to in the near future
and certainly by the next election the
establishment of a Margate Town Council
so the same thing could happen in
Margate
thank you
agenda item 7K question number 11 from
the member regarding manston airport I
called upon councilor Rogers
thank you chairman
my question is for the leader
Canterbury city council and Dover
district council have both had a
detailed presentation by River Oak at
their four councils
Council agreeing objected to a
presentation at the overview and
scrutiny committee and suggested it was
delayed until after the court case 5th
6th of July which was granted
my question is as manston airport is in
thanet can all councilors receive a full
presentation by Tony freudman director
of River Oak not just those members on
the overview and scrutiny committee
thank you
thank you I call upon councilor Everett
to respond
thank you councilwilders I think you
lost the last sentence of your question
which said that all councilors deserve
to know the true facts so residents of
planet can be better informed just being
helpful obviously
um
so um
just let's rehearse that where we are
shall we the development control order
application made by River Oaks strategic
Partners was initially granted by the
Department of Transport in July 2020. it
was subsequently crossed by the high
court in February 2021 following an
application for a judicial review of the
decision the Secretary of State at the
time conceded that the decision approval
letter issued did not contain enough
detail to support the decision
subsequently the DCI was granted for a
second time in August 22 by the minister
of Transport this second decision has
also been the subject of a traditional
application which was considered by the
high court earlier this month uh earlier
this month we can cut we're currently
awaiting the outcome of this hearing I'm
sure that's true of all of us
um Council Rogers you'll be aware that
Mr Fryman previously attended a member's
briefing at this Council I think in 2021
I'm not sure how much has changed since
then as for True Facts I'm not sure that
Mr freudman has a monopoly on those in
fact I'm quite certainly doesn't
one thing which certainly wasn't a fact
despite appearing on thousands of
conservative election leaflets was the
claim that voting conservative would
mean the airport would reopen and voting
labor would mean that it wouldn't
the true fact in that respect was that
the decision is after this council's
hands
but if the conservatives want to
interpret the result as a rejection of
the airport then it won't be me arguing
with them
once the outcome of the judicial review
process is known we would be happy to
arrange for members to be briefed on
what it means for the future and that
would include involving any relevant
parties at that stage
thank you councilor Rogers do you have a
supplementary question please I do thank
you there's a lot of misinformation
printed on social media including some
by funnel councilors and a lack of
accurate up-to-date knowledge do you
agree that counselors whatever their
personal views should be able to have
access to the correct information thank
you call upon counselor
no
um yeah there's a lot of misinformation
on social media I'm with you there I
think that's true about virtually every
topic that this Council discusses and
that's just where we are in the world
I'm afraid
um yeah absolutely I think the facts are
important I think that you know there
are facts on both sides of this argument
and councils to debate on the basis of
facts and not what they want to believe
is true or what nobody on social media
and we'll try and we'll try and
facilitate that thank you
agenda item 7l question number 12 from a
member of regarding Park in review I
called upon councilor Dawson
the chairman and good evening Council
and this question is for councilor Kane
um Can councilor Kane please update the
Council on where we are with the parking
review
that was sent out to Tender under the
previous administration
thank you I've called upon councilor
Keen to respond
chair and thank you councilor Dawson
the parking review was delayed because
of Staffing Resources and actually
didn't go out to Tender under the
previous administration however I'm
pleased to say that it will be live on
the tender portal within the next week
as part of the review stakeholders
including councilors will be involved in
providing feedback on the needs of the
district
as the dosage of a supplementary yes I
do chairman a supplementary question is
will the labor Administration look at
options such as a public consultation to
ensure the council works with businesses
and residents across than it so the
policy that the parking review will
influence is fair for all residents and
local businesses thank you
the code upon cancer came to respond
please
for that question and again I'm very
pleased to say that part of the tender
is for a full public consultation which
will include not only councilors but the
public in people that live or work in
thanet or people with interest in thanet
and as wide stakeholders as we can
engage
[Applause]
agenda item 7 m question 13 from a
member regarding empty homes are called
upon councilor Austin
thank you chair very pleased to be
bookending with my colleague here and
very nice to see that there are
questions other than from the green
party in this Council my question is to
councilor Whitehead with Rising rents
and mortgage costs and a shortage of
affordable homes we all know many
residents are struggling to keep a roof
over their heads Meanwhile we're also
aware we have empty homes in the
district and the simplest most cost
effective most sustainable way to
increase the housing supplies to make
sure those are filled
this Council has had success in filling
empty homes previously through the no
use empty scheme could councilor
Whitehead please update us on current
estimates of how many empty homes in the
district might be available for
occupation that's not including second
homes airbnbs and the like let us know
what's happening to get as many of these
occupied as possible and tell us whether
her Administration plans to set targets
for getting empty homes occupied thank
you
a call upon councilor White Hope to
respond
thank you chair and thank you very much
for your question councilor Austin
I frequently receive and answer
questions on empty homes and it's a
topic I've explored at length on many
occasions so apologies to those of you
who have experienced this before and it
is a very important issue without doubt
but I would disagree with the assertion
that bringing empty homes back into
usage is the simplest and cheapest way
to increase the housing Supply as if
that were true canceled across the
country would not be facing significant
numbers of empty properties
the key issue here is the difference
between private and public ownership and
the relative Powers have councils have
in relation to both
empty properties within our portfolio
can and will be brought back into usage
we have legal ownership and we can take
action to make that happen
in terms of our ownership we currently
have 11 properties that would be
classified as empty properties
seven of these are fire damaged
three or welfare units and one is
currently under consideration for future
housing plans
these properties can be brought back
into use or already have future use and
we will be acting to ensure that they
full of fulfill a very necessary social
use
properties owned by private individuals
are not within our jurisdiction in the
same way and our powers are exceedingly
Limited in terms of direct actions that
we can take to bring them back into
usage
and the reason for the existence of
empty properties is often not simple
frequently involving complex probate
issues of capacity and illness
lengthy multi-agency approaches often
spanning years aren't often necessary to
bring even severely dilapidated homes
into use
and a property in private ownership
simply being empty without links to
lapidation or significant social
disruption is not grounds to bring it
into public hands as they are considered
private assets with legal protections
relating to that
the key indicator for measurement here
is the number of homes registered as an
occupied and unfurnished for more than
six months on the council tax register
this overall figure is broken down into
two years of which we have 953
properties
two to five years 112 properties
five to ten years 40 properties and over
10 years 19 properties
the combined number as of the 3rd of
July 2023 is 1124.
empty homes undergoing structural
alterations and major repairs are
eligible for a 12-month discount due to
the importance of providing housing
stock in good condition
there are 112 homes subject to such a
discount
a further 315 properties have been left
empty for more than six months for
varying reasons but primarily as they
are awaiting probate as referenced
earlier
in total the council believes that there
are
1551 long-term empty homes their star of
concern and that we continue to monitor
so to recap in total we estimate that
there are 1551 properties that are
currently long term empty of differing
duration
1540 of these properties are privately
owned
we do currently have a dedicated
full-time empty homes officer as
referenced
their role is to engage with the owners
of empty homes to help them bring their
properties back into use with support
via the no use empty scheme
when the informal approach is
unsuccessful the council considers
whether there are any appropriate legal
powers that could be used to help bring
about reoccupation
it should be noted however that it is
not unlawful to own an empty home
we offer loans and support via no use
empty to bring properties requiring work
back into usage
this has been very successful
we have also previously increased
council tax on long-term empty
properties to up to three times standard
rate dependent on how long the property
is empty these all act as incentives to
bring property back into usage
our Target for the 23-24 year is to help
bring 120 long-term empty homes back
into use
our empty properties officer Works
incredibly hard and we will continue to
support those efforts
although the overall number of empty
properties is often quoted it is also
worth noting that over the past 15 years
our Council has been the most successful
local Authority in the whole of Kent in
terms of empty property interventions
and in the number of homes brought back
into use
this is a statistic that is often
forgotten in these discussions
thank you Council Austin have have your
supplementary question I'd have to yes
thank you thank you very much councilor
Whitehead for that full and detailed uh
explanation I'm sure that most members
will have noted eagerly in their local
government information unit bulletin
this morning a report on um from the
all-party Parliamentary group on ending
homelessness which is looking at
commercial properties owned by councils
and uh concluded that
um seven percent of office space and 14
of retail units in England are vacant
and of those councils own 6 000
commercial properties that have been
empty for over a year and could be
converted into homes do we have any
plans to explore whether we own any such
properties that might be right for
conversion
thank you for that that's a lovely
question
I think one of the issues
ironically enough relates to the
sustainability of buildings that have
been used for business
um in the currently especially within
our own portfolio we are looking at how
we make buildings energy efficient how
we increase ratings and how we future
proof the way we develop and build
a lot of the issues in terms of sort of
High Street developments or business
conversions
center around the fact that is
incredibly difficult to make these
buildings energy efficient
um
and at a point where we're trying to
bring
Energy Efficiency to the heart of what
we're doing in terms of Housing
Development
I can see that would be both challenging
and probably
are counter-intuitive thing to do I
accept the matter of space but it's
whether it will produce the quality of
accommodation that we want so I'm more
than happy to look at what we have but
that would be my major concern in terms
of using business space thank you thank
you Council Whitehead thank you agenda
item eight notice of motion one notice
of motion has been received in
accordance with the council procedure
rule three
please note the time allow for this
consideration of motion shall not exceed
30 minutes I have asked to be successant
as possible
agenda item 8A motion regarding pausing
new planning permission for major
applications are called upon Council of
Garner
thank you chair
as you will all have read in the paper
attached to the agenda the motion I'm
proposing this evening is asking Council
to pause a granting of new planning
permissions for builds of more than 10
dwellings to allow for a view into the
impacts of current house building
program is having across than it
as you will also have read in the
attached papers officers need to produce
a full report into the potential
planning
legal and financial impacts of this
motion to enable and informed debate so
I'm going to be asking you to vote to
enable officers to do this so that we
can return in October to have that
debate
as for the motion as far as a motion is
concerned
we're all familiar with the concerns
about southern Waters infrastructure
have been mentioned a few times already
tonight
it's not for purpose either to
consistently guarantee a supply of fresh
drinking water to us all or to
effectively deal with the associated
sewage and any heavy rainfall without
polluting the sea devastating the biod
of Earth First here around the coastline
and impacting local businesses
especially during the upcoming tourist
season
other infrastructure related concerns we
are all familiar with are the impacts on
GP surgeries the hospital schools and of
course the road Network the house
building program also raises a number of
other con questions which need to be
addressed some of which are going to be
discussed in later items tonight
how many previously approved planning
applications are being Sat On by
Developers
why are so many properties left empty
and not made available as primary
residences including many of the new
houses being built and how many
previously approved affordable homes
have actually been built and made
available at affordable prices
I'm sure we've all had conversations
with residents on their concerns about
the infrastructure impacts I've
mentioned concerns I'm sure that
featured prominently in most of our
election campaigns and concerns which
get raised regularly when significant
planning applications are discussed
around the district from Westwood to
birchington Via Westgate and Garland
there are concerns that we as a council
should have the opportunity to address
that's why I'm asking you to vote in
favor of us asking officers to produce a
full report into these potential
planning legal and financial impacts of
the motion and allow us to come back in
October for fully informed public debate
on the motion thank you
[Applause]
right I I call upon councilor Everett to
respond
thank you chair uh thank you councilor
Garner for your motion
um first thing to say is that I
recognize that it deals with real
concerns in our community and indeed
within the council
I do think that there is a risk however
that encourages the public to believe
that the council can do things that he
can't do
I'm also not clear why some of the
questions uh referenced in it the
matters referenced and it can't be dealt
with through existing channels
or how the answers will be carried into
policy other than through the existing
local plan review
however rather than close down the
debate at this point I think it's in
everybody's interest that officers do
produce a report which sets out the
legal and financial issues
that means that we can have an informed
debate in October and I think that
everybody will look forward to that
thank you
just point it out to me uh counseling
Island have you got a second for this
I'm sure we have
yeah
just that that's it yeah would members
please note that in courts with comes
the procedure rule 3.7 it is not agreed
to debate the motion it will fall as
only the council can agree this motion
can I have a propose in a second for
this debate this motion right
what should we do members agree to
debate the motion
that's
right that's fine
so uh yep
right
Council will agree that they both debate
the issue paragraph 3.8 of the
Constitution states that we ate the
council should not debate any motion
which would give rise to a significant
change to the income of the council
to its expenditure or contract terms
unless it is received a report from the
chief financing officer or the
monitoring officer as appropriate
setting out the legal or financial
effects of the motion
after the discussion with both planning
and legal departments this motion has
the potential to have major impact on
costs incurred by the council due to
potential action from developers through
claims
of known determination as such in Coates
with paragraph 3.8
the council should not debate this
motion at this meeting and defer it to
next meeting of the council a full
report of the financial impact of the
proposed motion can then be written for
members consideration so that an
informed debate can take place at
October council meeting thank you
less noise
right agenda item nine leaders
[Music]
thank you uh chair this is my first
report to Council of this Administration
and the first by a labor majority leader
in thanet since 2003.
and I am proud that this new labor
Administration begins with the plan on
tonight's agenda for a major extension
of genuinely affordable Council housing
for residents in need
there is nothing that we do here which
has more impact on the lives of
residents than providing housing and I
know because I represent Newington where
housing issues lose larger than
elsewhere
I know because I grew up in Council
housing with five of us in a two-bedroom
flat until we got the opportunity to
move into a brand new three-bedroom
Council house with a garden and I know
the difference it makes for a child to
have a space of their own in which to
study and for the whole family to have
peace of mind that they're not going to
be evicted at short notice so Make Way
for someone who can pay a higher rent
the reality for many of the 1600 local
households on our waiting list those in
temporary accommodation and many others
in the private rented sector is that
they are not in that position their
living arrangements are often precarious
and inadequate
addressing that situation with rent that
is genuinely affordable for as many
residents as we can is fundamental to
this labor Administration and I pay
tribute to the great work of our
officers in housing and finance who have
turned our Ambitions into an achievable
plan as well as to our labor Cabinet
member and my Deputy leader councilor
Whitehead whose commitment on housing
issues is recognized across this Council
the 400 homes we intend to secure across
the four-year life of this Council will
make a dent in our housing list it will
change the lives of those thanet
residents who benefit for the better it
will start this month with 42 new build
properties at Spitfire green
but I say to the council as I said to
the director of place when he first
shared his detailed Report with me I
want more
we will do everything we can and
hopefully with the help of an incoming
labor government of Westminster to do
even better for those in need
to be clear this housing isn't a
monetary cost to Residents generally the
ring fence budget which underpins it is
financed by borrowing from future rent
income right to buy receipts and grants
that cannot be spent in other areas and
it's important to say that because we
know that many of the other services we
provide to all our residents remain
severely stretched
Weimer Springs similar ambition to these
parts of the council but we must also be
honest about what we inherit and the
scale of the challenge
residents tell us that the state of our
public toilets isn't good enough and
they aren't open long enough
they tell us that our multi-story car
parks are unwelcoming and difficult to
access and they complain about grass not
being cut off them enough in parks and
Open Spaces fly tipping and a lack of
street cleaning in residential areas and
we know they're correct because we're
all residents too
and because our public spaces shape
everyone's perception of the district
whether as residents or visitors who are
so vital to our economy we recognize
that the council needs to do debt UPS
and to be clear this isn't a failure on
the part of our existing staff there
simply Aren't Enough of them
Financial pressures are a major
constraint on what we can do and even
more so in an era of rampant inflation
the amount that the council has to spend
has fallen sharply in real terms even
while residents have seen their council
tax rise each year
fortunately we have a great team of
senior officers currently being
strengthened further by an array of new
recruits
I know that collectively they have a
strong commitment to thanet and are as
anxious as we are to make those
improvements
I'm delighted that Colleen Carmichael
has agreed to continue as interim chief
executive for the time being with
council's approval tonight in order that
we can all draw on his experience for a
little longer and I know that he's
earned the respective councils across
the chamber in the short time that he's
been here
the leveling up award for Ramsgate the
successful bid for which was put
together under the minority labor
Administration two years ago is a
fundamental part of our plans
this is because it has the potential not
just to utilize the port to a much
greater extent than since 2013 and to
provide jobs and training for local
people but also because it can unlock
additional income for the council to
spend on Frontline Services across the
aisle
that is why both main parties on the
council have been committed to it and
next week the public will have a chance
to see for themselves how the leveling
up plans are progressing
importantly we've recently begun the
process of seeking an operator to run
birth two and three and I'm confident
that this will be successful
Way Station opens in 18 days time
through the southeast local Enterprise
partnership the getting building fund
and the new stations fund this
represents a 30 million pounds national
capital investment in the future of our
district half as much again as the
leveling up a wall for Ramsgate
all of the bodies responsible have
committed this money because they
believe partway will support growth in
the local economy
that has long been the view of this
Council too and I believe that in five
or ten years time those who continue to
claim otherwise will have been
comprehensively proven wrong
one of the things that Mr Carmichael has
been leading on as head of paid service
has been negotiations with the GMB over
their pay claim for cleansing staff
these discussions are strictly a matter
for officers but the Fallout from them
is very definitely something for members
this dispute is something else we
inherited from the previous Council and
despite talks taking place by our acas
which resulted in improved officer staff
strike action remains a threat
an issue that is close to the hearts of
many residents is the future of
margate's Winter Gardens
recently the cabinet member for property
and regeneration councilor Duckworth and
I were given a personal tour of the
building mostly by Torchlight and
including the behind the scenes area
where most of us were never previously
have been
well we can argue about the Rights and
Wrongs of the decision to close the
Winter Gardens it is obvious to anyone
who's been there in recent years that it
has suffered from Decades of under
investment which now needs to be put
right
that's going to be a major job with an
estimated six million pound price tag
and it's going to require external
funding to make it happen
that is what this council is working
towards and shortly we will begin
marketing it to potential operators to
gauge their interest
but I want to make it very clear that
this Administration will do everything
it can to restore the Winter Garden both
structurally and in terms of its status
as an iconic entertainment venue for the
local community and Beyond
but we must also be candid that there
will be no quick fix
in the meantime our priority is to keep
the building safe even though we
understand that the security and safety
measures we need to take to do that
could give the impression that we're
giving up on it that is very far from
being the case
members will be aware that Kent County
Council recently put forward proposals
to close the Richboro household waste
and recycling center permanently and to
reduce the operating hours at the
Margate Center to five days a week
I took the opportunity to speak to Roger
Goff the KCC leader about this and
subsequently wrote to Susan Kerry KCC
Cabinet member for the environment
particularly objecting to the fact that
all three options in their proposed
consultation included closing
richborough which is used by many FANUC
residents
and I'm pleased to note that they
subsequently announced a revised
consultation including Options under
which deal with clothes instead of
Richboro
kcc's financial difficulties have led to
other proposed service cuts and building
closures in thanet affecting sure start
and now the youth service none of which
are welcome to us
in the case of the recycling centers we
have concerns about congestion around
the entrance to the Margate one on
weekdays because of conflicts with
vehicles accessing our own Depot
there is also significant potential for
additional fly tipping which in effect
means that kcc's saving is an extra cost
for this Council
we will continue to Lobby KCC to
maintain both centers
together with officers I recently met
representatives of the local government
boundary commission for England who
advised that they will be carrying out a
review of The District Council wall
boundaries over the next year or so
this is something they do periodically
to ensure that as far as possible the
population has equal representation
and clearly there have been significant
changes to its distribution since the
current boundaries came into effect in
this process May well result in fannet
having fewer District councilors after
2027. something which will probably
please many of the commentators on
social media or message source and it's
also something I personally support
but this is up for discussion I can
understand that it may be unsettling for
members
to find that they've just been elected
to a ward that isn't going to exist in
the same way after the next election
but overall this process is long overdue
we will also need to carry out a
community governance review to redraw
the boundaries for the towns and
potentially the parishes if we don't
want to have a very confusing set of
local elections in 2027. this does
however potentially provide a way
forward for the establishment of a
Margate Town Council the boundary
Commissioners will be speaking to all
group leaders next week where the
members briefing on the process the
following September
finally we're now coming into the peak
period performance tourist industry and
therefore an important time for our
local economy and the numerous small
businesses who generate revenue and
provide jobs
I hope for the benefit of them as well
as the rest of us that the next couple
of months will continue to bring good
weather but I also recognize that this
brings particular stresses for residents
who live closest to our most popular
beaches
the council continues with its speech
management activity and will work
closely with other key agencies to try
to minimize problems for residents and
visitors alike it is disappointing that
we've had to take temporary measures to
control access to parts of the harbor
arm in Ramsgate to try to prevent young
people putting themselves in serious
danger in and around the water there on
the hottest day but it is the
responsible thing for us to do
despite the challenges the hotter
weather brings including in this chamber
I wish everyone a prosperous and
enjoyable summer rest assured that
whatever the temperature we will be
working hard behind the scenes to bring
forward the positive changes that people
voted for in May
call upon cancer Pew to comment on or
ask questions in relationship to the
leaders report
I will chair thank you and thank you I
thank the leader for his report
uh Thursday I'd like to thank the leader
for advanced sight of his report before
today
thank you for that Interruption um and
of course to congratulate him on
becoming leader of the council I'm sure
he would agree with me that he certainly
has some big shoes to fill his
predecessor took many of the difficult
decisions that no one else would and has
set this Council on course to truly
deliver for all Planet residents
I know the leader's remarks on the
proposals to provide more affordable
housing and welcome the proposals that
will be put forward later by Council of
Whitehead however rather than purchase
affordable housing from developers
whilst we have a waiting list of over
1600 local residents would it not my
question to the leader would it not be
better for TDC to build our own
affordable housing and will the leader
commit to ensuring that we stop
developers from providing less than the
30 affordable homes that is a policy
within our local plan within their sites
when it is urgently needed every time a
developer argues down the percentage of
affordable homes on their sites we are a
step further away from securing much
needed homes for those most in need
it is interesting to note that the
leader includes references to the
Ramsgate level and up fund which the
previous conservative Administration
worked very hard to progress
but he is neglected to mention the
Margate digital project which was
submitted by and secured under the
previous conservative Administration
something that we were incredibly proud
to have done only a week into taking
over control of the council
Margate digital has the potential to
provide important educational courses
for not just local people but to attract
more people to the than area to study
in relation to the round to get living
up fund I'm sure the leader will agree
that it is important that the council
delivers on all of the various projects
not just some of them and with what I've
heard previously of the fish at the
proposals to move the fisherman's
facilities and that they were provided
with a proposal that was considerably
over budget
um will projects be at risk of not being
delivered
we're incredibly unfortunate of course
to have secured two loaning up funds for
thanet and so will the leader again
confirm that his administration will
seek to deliver both of these as a
priority not just one
in relation to the Winter Gardens I hope
the leader in Council datworth certainly
enjoyed their tour of the building and
I'm glad to hear they appreciated the
uniqueness of the building and the
structure itself considering much of the
false rhetoric that came from the labor
group under the previous Council about
the Winter Gardens and that we and that
I know I met with many interested
parties
um who may be able to renovate and
operate the Winter Gardens before the
local elections it appears that this
labor Administration will continue to
follow the program for identifying
potential operators that were set out by
the conservatives so I'm absolutely
delighted that councilor Yates continues
to agree with the program that I set out
and agreed
um well over a year ago it's absolutely
fantastic the leader mentions about
Richmond waste and recycling center I'm
delighted that the leader feels that his
contribution to not only Council agoff
but to relevant County cabinet minister
Cabinet member was worthwhile I know
that it was also or more importantly it
was the good work of not only the
conservative councils for sandwich
Cliff's end and Peg well and the
subsequent County Council is in sandwich
and the FANUC Villages that have worked
incredibly hard to ensure that those
options have been revised and that it's
not set the Richboro waste recycling
center will close because as I uh I
think it was last year I bumped into the
leader uh the now leader at the
recycling center it's important to know
that we both use that recycling center
and value it immensely
um so it's fantastic that there's a bit
of cross-party support on that but I
would like to say that it's a successful
campaign of conservative councils in the
area that have resulted in that change
and the leader talks about review of
Ward boundaries and I agree that it's
long overdue and I hope that as as this
will affect all councilors that the
process for this will be as open and
transparent as possible and I think we
can all agree considering I think we're
the second largest local Authority by
council is in the entirety of Kent that
it's long overdue that we reduce our
numbers and I think residents expect
that from us as well
um the process to establish a Margaret
Town Council is also long overdue and I
hope that the leader can confirm that
this will be given as much priority
given that it was not under uh it was
not under the previous labor
Administration and finally I would like
to add that it's I think we've seen it
tonight really
um that it's interesting to see this
labor Administration continue to try and
uh blame the previous concern
Administration for any questions that
they don't really want to answer I hope
that that isn't going to be a recurring
theme over this labor Administration
however long it lasts
um
but what I would ask but what I would
ask is that it's important considering
how small the Labor's majority is in
this chamber and it is it's lovely to
see so many such red in here of course
um the the labor Administration works
with all councilors cross-party on many
key issues and as much as it can get
political in here let's not get nasty
and let's act like adults
I grew upon the leader to respond
um thank you Council Pugh for your for
your response and um you know good to
see you here tonight I'm sorry you
couldn't make it last time
um but
leaving the group
um you know I I I share your um I'll
show you your appreciation to councilor
Ashby actually I met councilor Ashby uh
earlier this week I had a chat with her
and no doubt you know you've been
speaking to her as well so you'll know
that she's getting on fine and I wish
her well
um
yeah we do want to build um affordable
housing on uh as well as buy properties
but the difficulty as you all know is is
finding the land and there is a program
for building uh
new Council housing on the land that we
do have and if we can identify more land
that we can raise the money to do it
then it will certainly be doing that as
well
but this is a new opportunity and I'm
really pleased that we've been able to
bring it forward as to whether we can
stop developers
um
walking away from the 30
threshold the reality is that that's
about viability in the planning process
as you well knows and unfortunately
developers who can prove that the
development isn't viable with 30
planning are able to secure permission
with a lower percentage
um that's more unacceptable to us than
anybody but that's where we are legally
and again we have to talk about what the
law allows us to do not what we'd like
to do
I certainly accept that the what he says
about the Margate digital project I've
really I've got the Ramsgate leveling up
finding my mind because of the
exhibition next week but I hope we can
take that forward and I'm sure there'll
be more information about that coming
out in the near future but we're
committed to all the schemes including
the Margate Town deal
um
yes inflation is having its effect on
the living upper walls particularly I
know some of the details about what's
happening in Ramsgate we'll be talking
more about that at the cabinet meeting
in August and obviously we'll have an
opportunity to discuss it then
I can't speak for Council Yates about
the Winter Gardens I'm sure that he's
quite capable of arguing his own case in
terms of
yeah in terms of where we're going with
it certainly we're following the the
process that uh the conservative group
would outline we're also looking at
other options I think the main thing is
that we get the Winter Gardens open that
we get the investment in the building
and we restore it to its proper status
um at the top of margate's entertainment
Bill alongside Dreamland I think we all
want that and how we do it I think uh
well there's certain different options
but we'll see
um
Rich well well let's see what happens
I'm always amused by the idea of
conservative councils campaigning
against the conservative Council
um yeah I'm not claiming that I got them
to change the consultation the fact is
they did change the constellation after
I wrote for them but I think they were
coming under pressure from various
directions
um Margate Town Council during the last
Labor Administration well as as you will
recall there was a little thing called
Covey going on which actually
significantly distracted the whole
Council during that period so it would
have been difficult I think to have been
embarked on that particularly the
Signature Collection exercise during the
Kobe epidemic
um and uh yeah you say it's a small
majority it's a bigger majority than the
conservatives have had here since 2011 I
think
celebrity
I called upon counselor Garner to
comment or ask questions in relationship
to the leaders report
thank you chair
well I'd also like to start by
congratulating cancer effort and his
group on achieving an overall majority
and to wish him well as leader of our
Council
I'm sure there will be occasions when we
disagree with him on policy decisions
and on priorities and I might mention
one or two later in this response but we
will I'm sure be able to do this with
Civility and with the best interest of
the community at heart
I'd also like to take this opportunity
if I may to thank the previous leader
Ashby for all the hard work she put in
over the time she led the council
to get the resolution of the significant
governance issues we're all aware of
Over The Line work with this work which
this new Council will benefit from going
forward I wish her all the best for the
future
the provision of more Council for
housing is certainly something we
welcome and I hope we as a council will
be able to build up our stock of council
owned homes over the next few years
we were encouraged by the assurances we
got at the members briefing early this
week that as well as being affordable in
terms of rent we'll be doing everything
we can to make sure our housing is also
affordable to run in terms of energy
costs I properly constructed an
insulated and without gas boilers
and we hope this approach will extend to
other sustainability measures such as
solar panels rainwater capture
etc for the benefit of residents the
area and for the planet
we recognize the excellent work being
done by housing on the decarbonisation
of our social housing and hope we can
build on this
we also welcome your commitment to
Bringing similar ambition to other parts
of the council as things like litter
public toilets and parking make a
massive difference to the quality of
life of residents and the quality of
experience of our visitors
the growing number of examples around
the district where improvements have
been made through engagement with
Community groups which I think we need
to build on
whilst we're all members of the public
who prefer a tidy approach to parks
there is a way of combining tidy with
managed habitat creation that Whelan
does increase people's enjoyment of Open
Spaces
this can be seen in Ellington Park in
Tivoli Park and Limington green Westgate
where the Public's response to Meadow
creation a couple of years ago elicited
600 emails to the Westgate Parish
Council expressing happiness with the
scheme
we have seen similar in Boar's deserts
Peters over the last couple of years
which the Town Council there are looking
to build on
thanet Parkway we disagree
another station in thanet permanently
unmanned that can only be reached by car
with a bus stop that will likely only be
used when the bus Replacement Service is
running at a cost of 20 million pounds
30 million pounds sorry better correct
39. two million pound of which comes
from TDC reserves make no sense makes no
sense not just to us but also some
members of all the other parties
the only growth it will encourage is of
Housing and Industrial Estates in the
surrounding fields it is however a
reality as you say now so I guess we
will have to wait five or so years to
see who was right
in the meantime though I'm sure one
aspect that we can agree on
is that the tree and Shop planting
around the station a lot of which has
already started to die needs to be
replaced and maintained and I'd ask if
you could use your influence to join us
in putting pressure on the developers to
take action
moving on we also deploy the kcc's
decision to close the household waste
center at Richboro and agree it's likely
to increase fly tipping for surrounding
District councils to a good to deal with
we recognize the pressures on kcc's
budget but we will join the
administration lobbying then to make
sure this and other centers remain open
as Peak tourism period approaches
bringing the major business benefits the
district relies on it is important that
we do more for residents especially
around the coastline who are adversely
impacted as an example over the weekend
uh
21st of June for the residents of Botany
Bay it brought major disruption
surrounding road to a gridlocked as
hundreds of motorists were funneled into
narrow and congested residential streets
seem the oblivious to signs displaying
limited parking at Botany Bay
during this time it was not possible for
many residents to leave their properties
and if Emergency Services required they
will not be able to attend
and I'm sure this is replicated in other
areas around the district
this is dangerous and working with the
police and other agencies we need to do
more to come up with Creative Solutions
to this problem
for all the reasons you highlighted
about the significance and potential of
the 11 up bid we'd like to see regular
updates on the externally funded
regeneration program we welcome the new
administration's expressed commitment to
transparency and look forward to sharing
a lot more information about this
program with our residents and receiving
their feedback starting with next week's
open events in manscape
and I'd like to finish things with times
up I'd like to finish by saying how
pleased we are to note the new senior
appointments and we're delighted that
Colin has agreed to stay on for a
further year subject to approval this
evening we'd like to thank him for his
hard work and positive and constructive
approach we'd also like to register our
appreciation for the hard work of our
officers at all levels and recognize the
extra stress they've been under in
recent years which we hope is now
reducing thank you
[Applause]
thank you councilor Garner and um
I think you know that um
all the leaders of this Council have
over the last four years
um had a pretty amicable relationship
and I certainly include yourself and I
include the the conservative leadership
so sometimes when people see us have
little Spats in the council chamber they
get a false idea about how we cooperate
um behind the scenes um because I think
we all do we have different ideas but we
do all want the best of the planet and
some of the things I've talked about
tonight in terms of the public realm I
think we'd all like to do better it's
just a question of finding the way to do
it
um so we're going to have a fresh look
at things and see what we can do better
and that includes things like um half
the situation of Bosley Bay
um and I can't promise we'll do
everything but I can say that we'll try
um
there wasn't a lot that you said which
was contentious or I disagree with you
know we can go over the Planet Parkway
question as many times as you like I'm
happy to look at the um the planting
around it I think that there needs to be
a bus service there
um it's not quite true that everybody
has to arrive by car some people live in
Cliff scene
um but I think that the arguments that
have often been made about the station
are come from the wrong place people say
I'm not going to go there from I'm not
going to drive there from ramsgo I can
get to Ramsgate station well that's what
we want people to do what we didn't want
people to do was to drive to Ramsgate
station and parking station approaching
Wilfred Road and over congest that area
and there is a problem with people
parking in those roads and using the
station
um but it's not just about that it is
about growth it is about the future it
is about attracting new people to come
to Planet it's about interacting more
investment into thanet and it is about
housing it is about housing let's be
honest about it it's always been about
housing as well as everything else
um I believe the station will be a
success I don't know whether it would be
success on day one or week one or month
one but I believe over time we'll come
to recognize it and the biggest thing is
it's no threat whatsoever to any of the
other stations it was never going to be
well they were never going to turn
trains around there and all the other
nonsense has been talked about it is
really not worth discussing any further
thank you God call upon councilor borrow
to comment on or or ask questions in
relationship to the leaders
thank you chairman and congratulations
to councilor Everett and to
the labor group
last time I made report was an
independent group that it was eight
years ago so please forgive me if I'm a
little bit Rusty
um
I'm gonna make it quick because I think
I'd rather get to the point and say a
few things rather than just go on them
or everyone
um
I've just come back from a lovely
holiday in the south of France with some
former colleagues I had a really really
good time there and you know what I was
going to read this but
I'm not going to make it too clinical
one of the things that really pushed me
into coming back on the council
yeah I've been in that group and I've
been in that group but one thing that
really made me come back
is something
personal and close to my own heart
I live in briary close I think a few
people in the gallery know where bribery
closes it's a place where
a beautiful field has been built on
been there for many many years
and we're
afraid that the same thing's going to
happen anyway I'm going to get to the
point now the point I'm making is I was
in Provence and this beautiful
countryside there it's lovely the
quality of life people are happy people
are smiling you know happy it's good for
you to be happy and that was one thing
that really touched me let's not take
ourselves too seriously and that's one
thing I promised myself to do now I'm a
counselor again take myself to can you
just comment on the leaders report
please I'm will and I think the leaders
report was absolutely wonderful chair
thank you and I tell you what
my friend counselor Everett has made
some wonderful promises and he's got
four years to make them all happen I
mean lots of people in the past are
previous leaders Chancellor Johnson
councilor Hart and others Etc councilor
bayford well they've tried all these
things and they haven't really got very
fast so let's hope the cancer ever it
can achieve something that they that
they didn't achieve finally and I said I
was going to make it short and I do
apologize chair for going on a bit too
long
one does do that sometimes
let's hope that we're not going to be so
Ramsgate Centric
what about Westgate and Garland let's do
some more things for Westgate and
Garland what about Road sweepers on the
streets of of Michelle Avenue
very close what about looking after the
people of Westgate and Garland and
birchington even
you know it's not just south FedEx North
that it does exist chairman chairman
thank you very much for allowing me to
go on and councilor Everett wish you all
the best hope you can get some results
boy
[Applause]
yeah call upon the leader to respond
well um thank you councilwarrow and uh
of course um you and I both know that we
stood together in uh East Cliff for the
labor party in
2015. yeah unsuccessfully on that
occasion perhaps that was good Council
to be out of with hindsight
um so we go back a number of years and I
thank you for your kind words
um it just the only thing I'm going to
comment on is in respect of the idea
that the the administration might be
dominated by Ramsgate let's be clear
about this there are six members of the
cabinet four of them represent Margate
Wards a fifth one represents a Ramsgate
Ward but lives in Margate I am the only
member of the cabinet who represents
Ramsgate Ward and lives in the Ramsgate
area so there's no traveling there's no
real risk of this Administration being
dominated by Ramsgate
um I'd like to talk more about
broadstairs and I'm delighted that I'm
going to get more information from my
colleagues in broadstairs label to do
that to understand it better and I'm
also going to draw on the expertise of
our new colleagues from Westbrook and
from Westgate in order to make sure that
we reflect the issues in that area as
well and we'll talk cross party to
people representing other ears including
councils
so you know I I live in Cliff's end not
quite Ramsgate
um is a village understands some of the
issues certainly there's people who'd
like to do lots of development in
Cliff's end so you know I'm not I'm not
entirely Urban and Ramsgate orientative
whatever some of you might want to
believe but the two perfect opportunity
will be over the next four years we will
do our best that's all I can say
thank you
agenda item 10 report of the chairman of
the overview and security panel I call
upon councilor fellows to present the
report
thank you uh Mr chairman members will
find my report in this evening's agenda
pack that's been circulated to everyone
we had a lively first meeting of this
term of the overview and security panel
on the 30th of May it was good to see
some new faces joining the scrutiny
panel as well as some familiarons
members of the scrutiny panel will be
finalizing the work program shortly for
the coming year we have a long list of
subjects and topics that we've been put
forward to review we probably have
enough to last us for four years
the next meeting of the scrutiny is next
Thursday the 20th of July where we've
invited the leader along to give us his
vision for done it for the next four
years also a number of subjects put
forward for scrutiny we're around the
leveling up projects and the town deal
so we've invited the relevant officers
to come along give us an update on all
the projects in thanet all members of
this Council are welcome along to
security panel meetings as well as all
members of the public so I hope to see
many of you there I'm happy to take any
comments questions or suggestions
literature
thank you
do members have any comments
no
in the item 11 appointment or monitoring
officer are called upon the leader
hopefully we'll have some different
items that other people can talk about
our future Council meetings
um
this report is regarding the appointment
of the council's monitoring officer
members will be aware that Ingrid Brown
has recently been appointed as head of
legal and democracy and she's expected
to join the council in October the
general purposes committee considered a
version of this report at its meeting on
Monday and made the following
recommendations of full Council the
Ingrid Brown be appointed as the
council's monitoring officer from her
first day of service that in the
meantime Samira Khan should continue in
that role until either she leaves the
council service or until Ingrid bounds
first day of service whichever is
earlier and they have Samira Khan leaves
the council service before Ingrid bound
begins Nick Hughes as Deputy monitor
monitoring officer should cover the role
for the interim period And I move these
recommendations
right agenda item 12 appointment of head
of pay services I call upon the leader
foreign
this report is regarding the appointment
of the council's head of paid service
members will be aware that Colin
Carmichael's existing contracts is due
to expire imminently and therefore it's
necessary to make arrangements to
continue to cover his role the
appointment of the head of paid service
is a decision for full Council to agree
I know that members across the council
have been impressed by Mr Carmichael's
contribution in the time that he's been
with us and we'll welcome his
willingness to continue for another year
however he isn't able to stay with us
for the longer term so during that year
the intention is to identify and appoint
his successor it's a considerable
advantage that Mr Carmichael is willing
to offer us both continuity and a level
of flexibility
the general purposes committee
considered a version of this report on
Monday and made the following
recommendations to council
a full Council to extend the appointment
of Colin Carmichael's interim chief
executive head of paid service and
returning officer for a further year
until the 31st of July 2024 and to note
that the appointments panel has the
responsibility of determining the timing
and process of the appointment of a
permanent chief executive and I move
these recommendations
you go
thank you chair
um it's my pleasure to present the
affordable housing delivery report
tonight
and to reiterate the recommendations
it is recommended that Council
firstly adopt the target to deliver at
least 400 new affordable homes by 2027
and agree the proposed funding and
delivery proposal set out in this report
secondly replace the current phased
approach to budgeting for the affordable
housing program with a single
Acquisitions and development budget
thirdly note that detailed projects will
be presented to the cabinet for approval
as they are identified
and finally approve an additional HRA
capital budget as 7.485 million to
deliver 51 new affordable homes are set
out in 3.3 and 3.4 below subject to
Cabinet approving the details
in relation to why this is coming
forwards
our housing list currently stands at 1
604 households
these are all individuals with an
identified and documented need for
housing
the actual number of households who
require support in accommodation is
without doubt much higher
almost all of us in this chamber will
have worked with individuals facing
these pressures already
some we can support
others are still struggling to navigate
and even access the private Market
rental rates across Planet are
increasing rapidly as our eviction
notices
properties that five years ago cost
around 600 pounds a month are now
routinely marketed for over 1 200.
and within our members briefing
organized earlier this week specifically
to discuss our changing approach we
explored the Stark disparity between
private rental rates and the rate of lha
our weekly genuinely affordable rate for
a three-bed property currently amounts
to 172 pounds per week below the local
housing allowance rate of 184 pounds and
11 Pence
the current average weekly private
market rate is 270 276 pounds 91 pounds
and 89 Pence above weekly local housing
allowance
and this is an average rate
three bed houses in Margate and
cliftonville when available often
routinely exceed 375 pounds per week 190
pounds 89 Pence above local housing
allowance rate
challenging times require skill and
creativity
both of which we have in abundance
within our housing team
I frequently speak highly of Housing and
with exceptionally good reason
the ambition and commitment within
housing is extraordinary and the work
that has gone into enabling this is a
perfect example
we have an established track record of
successfully delivering new genuinely
affordable rented homes and an absolute
commitment to delivering
even in challenging times we delivered
an average of 18 properties per year
when many councils choose not to deliver
housing and rely on the external Market
we are now aiming to increase that
delivery from 18 per year to over a
hundred
to indicate our competence in this area
we have completed 144 new homes since
our program started in 2015 through a
combination of construction buying new
homes and buying vacant buildings for
conversion
we already have funding and plans in
place for the construction of a further
47 homes and have earmarked 8.1 million
annually and our housing revenue account
business plan over the medium term
subject to around 40 of the cost coming
from external subsidy
but we need to do more for our residents
and deliver what is needed quickly and I
am delighted to be able to introduce
this report that sets out our ambition
and our methods to deliver over 400 new
affordable homes for rent over the
coming four years
it is well known by now that direct
funding to cancels to enable social and
genuinely affordable housing will not
cover all costs related to Blue element
our plans are based on 60 of the cost of
delivering this program being funded by
borrowing within our housing revenue
account with the remaining 40 coming
from external funding such as affordable
housing grants from homes England
section 106 planning agreements or the
receipts from right to buy sales
to give Financial Surety and security to
council and residents each individual
project will have its costs assessed
over its lifetime projected forward for
50 years and we will only proceed with
projects that both cover their costs and
are able to sustain the necessary
borrowing
this is best illustrated by our first
project set out in the report for the
purchase of 42 Homes at Spitfire green
which shows the revenue deficit in the
initial years but accumulates surpluses
in the long term that can be used for
further investment in homes and Housing
Services
this is an approach that builds upon
itself
a way to make housing actively work to
deliver further housing to make
genuinely affordable rent a reality in
Burnet
this report recommends the necessary 5
million pound budget to deliver the
first project of our exciting program
the report also recommends a budget for
a further early project for nine homes
with external match funding from the
government's local Authority housing
fund to be used initially for Refugee
families from Ukraine and Afghanistan
and subsequently let families from the
council's housing register
part of this project is funded by the
local Authority housing fund and due to
this funding this project will generate
surpluses from the very first year which
will be used to support further housing
projects
investment in housing is an investment
in the future of our residents and in
our future as a council
as such I am delighted to move the
recommendations in the report
okay could I have a second please thank
you
do members agree
yes
thank you
I agenda item 14 allowance report
recommendations from ukjirp
I moved the council notes the
recommendations of East Kent joint
independent Roman ocean panel be adopted
namely that it be recommended to Senator
Council that the members allowance
scheme to
2023-54 I sat out in Annex one of the
report be approved
pay increase
in respect of the Department careers
allowance
it's dependent carers allowance the
panel will propose a move to actual cost
refurbishment instead of refurbishment
of based on National living wage
can the vice chair please
second seconded yeah do members agree
debate
do we want to debate that
no
yeah
[Music]
I can take a shower hands off yeah right
so let's we have a show of hands then
please do members agree
no
members who disagree
right and there's any obsessions any
extensions any abstentions
that's a great okay that's agreed
thank you
item 15 representation of non-executive
outside bodies
I know that the recommendations are set
out in a report are adopted with the
vice chair please second seconded
do members agree agree thank you
agenda minus 16 the exclusion of press
on public
I move that the public and press be
excluded for the meeting for agenda item
17 as it contains exempt information as
defined in paragraph one and two of the
schedule 12a part 1 of The Local
Government Act 1972
with the vice chair please second
Ed do members agree
yeah right
can those in the public gallery now
leave the meeting to allow the council
to consider item 17 in private session
please